انضم الينا من موسكو مراسل صباح العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اولا اشكرك
على تواجدك معانا ودرجه الحراره 20 درجه
تحت الصفر في موسكو الان اا كيف يبدو
تفاعل الروس مع المونديال ما بين همم
حرمان المشاركه في المونديال وبروده الطقس
بدرجات حراره
اكبر تقارير الارصاد الجويه يزيد عن 20
درجه تحت الصفر لكن لكم
الدوله ارض الثلج بلاد السقيعه اللعب
الشعبيه الاولى فيها كره القدم انا الان
نقيم في المنطقه السكنيه التي اعيش فيها
في العاصمه موسكو لكم ما تتخيل انه مع هذه
هي الابنيه فيها يعني اطفال صغار لعب
وكبار يمارسون كره القدم في العديد من
المناطق والملاعب المونديال اليوم في ظل
الازمه الكبيره والازمه الاوكرانيه
والصراع الكبير بين موسكو والغرب يحمل في
طياته الكثير من الخيبه بالنسبه للجانب
الروسي موسكو وروسيا
كانوا قد شاركوا في التصفيات المؤهله
لمونديال قطر 2022 والجميع يعرف بان نسخه
قطر تاتي مباشره بعد نسخه روسيا التي فتحت
هذه الاراضي للعالم وتعرف الدول العالم
على الثقافه الروسيه وعلى شعبها لذلك طبعا
كان الروس يقفون موقفا الجد في رؤيه
المونديال خلال فصل الشتاء لكن ما يحدث من
ازمات وضغوطات وعقوبات اخرجت ان توب
الروسي من المنافسات قبل اللقاء بولندا
بالمناسبه التي تاهلت يوم امس الى الدور
القادم
يعني من الفساد المؤهله بسبب العقوبات
الغربيه وهنا طبعا نلاحظ بان بصمه السياسه
مرتبطه بشكل كبير ببصمه الرياضيه طبعا
الشعب هل ما حصل من معطيات مؤخرا افقد
الروس شغفهم شعبيه كره القدم اليوم هل في
ردات فعل بعضهم لا يتابع مثلا
وهم يقفون فقط مع منتخب صربيا وهو طبعا
صاحب الموقف السياسي ال- قريب من موسكون
وعن ما اذا صح طبعا موسكو تتابع كره القدم
الشعب الروسي عاشق لها لكن طبعا الجو الان
في موسكو وطبيعه الشتاء وعمل للناس
وخروجهم من ساعات الصباح الباكر الى ساعات
متاخره من الليل يحول دون متابعه مباريات
كره القدم التي تبدا في بعض الاحيان طبعا
قبل نهايه وقت العمل في الشركات التجاريه
لذلك من واحد بان الروسي يتجه من خلال
غرفه نهايه الاسبوع لمتابعه مباريات اما
الوضع الان فهو متجمد على الشكل الذي
ترونه
طبعا لا بد من لفت الانتباه سهام عن
المنتخب الروسي له هبات عبر التاريخ هو
متاخر في قضيه التطور في كره القدم لكن كل
عشر سنوات نلاحظ له بصمه واضحه في كره
القدم على سبيل المثال في عام 2018
بالمركز الثالث ببطوله اوروبا بطوله كره
القدم كان له اداء مشرف كبير جدا شكله
المنتخب السعودي في بطوله روسيا عام 2018
لكن في صراحه لو سمحت لابد من الحديد بان
يعني يتحدثون بالفكاهه بشكل كبير عن منتخب
بلادهم يعني العديد من الاقاويل والعديد
من القصص التي تبث
المنتخب بانها المدرب البولندي الشهير
الذي قاد منتخب روسيا منذ عام طبعا 2008
الى 2010 كانت له تجارب كبيره اما مع
منتخب هولندا او مع منتخبات اسيويه ووصل
بها الى مراحل متقدمه في كاس العالم لكن
عندما استلم دفه المنتخب الروسي لم يتاهل
وخرجت بعضها الى الشارع يعني نكته او مزحه
تداولها الروس بشكل كبير وهي تقول بان
بوسيدين دخل احد الرياضيه وهو طلب من
البائع اعطني لو سمحت كره سله وكره
الطائره ومضارب للعب التنس وحذيه للتزلج
وهم للسباحه وغير ذلك يعني البائع يتوقف
هو قال له يعني
بماذا يلعب لاعبون يعني او ما هي الرياضه
التي يمارسون حتى اساعدك ادوات الرياضيه
وقال انشدك انا اريد ان افهم ما هي هذه
الرياضه يعني هذا شيء تداول بروح الفكاهه
لدى الشعب الروسي ان كان في شاشات
التلفزيون وان كان وان كان في الاعلانات
وان كانت في حديثه نتمنى التوفيق
للارجنتين ما نسيتنا يا عبد الجواد مع انك
في موسكو مش رؤوس مش عم يتابعوا شكرا
مراسل صباح عربيه عبد الجواد الرشد